I'm all right well let's get this in
this is I'm going with this move right
now before d4 to avoid the Grunfeld so
keep that in mind if you're if you're
not too familiar with a particular
opening and you're wanting to at that
point as white avoid it you could run
with efore but there are opportunities
for black to have a say and maybe shift
gears and not allow white to get into a
king's we're not allowed white to get
into this particular formation maybe
there was a 4 in response mersing the e5
in response to e4 so I'm going to run
with f3 I think I play this more often
than any other set up in response to a
king's indian formation kingside fiend
keto f3 to guard both be four primary
reason however watch over G 4 I want to
play my bishop here lend support to d4
and not have to worry about Knight g4
kicking kicking it elsewhere this square
by the way is very important to watch
over why you might ask because the
bishop is here c5 or a 5 should be
played and I'm not so sure about the
bishop dr excuse me the night d7 move
because now i don't have to worry about
knight c6 being played and it's for that
reason that I'm able to play my Bishop
to d3 and have my queen not be in a
position where it's watching over d4
directly I think if black goes about
things differently with their night move
if knight c6 with the intention of 'if
I've was played then this Bishop d3 move
well I'd have to think twice about it
this move is actually a one that
concerns me
and by concern I mean it uh scares me a
little bit let's see what I'd do I'd to
offend my pond on be fish rook here
Queen c2 I'll Queen d3 to Queen d2 what
am i doing there was no fear there was
no fear right there could there be
tricks though Knight g4 with the
follow-up fork does not work because of
night d5 that's one way out of it I
think another way is just to be chopping
this pond most direct is just 95 these
guys right here a label that you can use
to describe both of these guys both
nights counterparts they're both
fighting for the same central squares
well you'll often find in chess is that
when one moves the other will move the
very next turn like right now he just
moved to the edge what squares you're
not controlling d5 what can use what
square could I make use of d5 with the
tempo all the more appealing might be
good on its own to just throw the knight
on d5 but now with tempo so this is a
number one candidate move forcing the
Queen back as a continuation what would
I have
I don't know but I'm still going to do
it because there is pressure on d4
there's a fork being threatened there so
let's chase the Queen back home
well it's castle my nights going to get
kicked away but that's all right or is
it yeah that's all right because now I
could look to focus on d6 now I could
say to myself if I capture if black
doesn't recapture with the pond it could
be a target and if it does recapture it
the pond then well that's probably best
okay well this is a little bit weird
here I think if the bishop place to this
square I want to shut the door on it so
Bishop d7 I just played d5 and slam the
door on the bishop have it bite at a
pond let's see what else is there if I'm
going to play d 5 i'll wait to do it I
want the bishop to first move here maybe
a 3 B 4 I like keeping this tension so
let's keep the tension
pawn takes I'll take with the night and
me to move like Knight e5 with Bishop c2
however maybe I want to watch over sea
for could see for have pressure on it
soon I don't know whoa okay let's see
what's going on here if I take the rook
can't recapture because there's forks so
if i take here how does my opponent
recapture let's take I'm taking away
from the center okay this square is back
too I like if I can make use of that now
what which faces my poor is placed
poorest place pieces my light square
Bishop i'm looking to rear out it this
would be a wonderful diagonal hits the
night prepares to exchange exchange
insaaf excuse me and and and and it
watches over ei indirectly let's go
there and this is very important because
guess what this is the only open file
and if there's a square that these rooks
are going to be pivoting on it's going
to be the e8 square so this night if it
moves it allows my bishop to see e8 and
cause a headache to the black rooks I
can also look into pond push bishop here
exchange LightSquared bishops pond
recaptures its past follow up with the
night d5 this could be a wonderful
square for my night my bishop has hit I
could do this as a counter this queen is
constrained to the defense of the night
I could take this night if i go here the
Queen can't go too far away what about
what's this rub doing nothing let's get
I'm doing something if it rip plays here
the night is pinned do I come here
because we might end up having just a
bunch of trades Bishop g5 Bishop f6 okay
now there's definitely that definitely
has to be a move here a block if i play
my bishop here
let's go here I want to keep a close eye
on this square well I'm doing this right
now because I'm seeing possibilities of
pivoting on e6 with my night and in two
moves I'm ready to do just that the
Queen better move tricks actually I
could have done that on my I didn't have
to make this pawn move I didn't have to
do that I still have rook rib they are
available Bishop back to ca might as
well because you're biting at this okay
now my book becomes incredibly active
okay the Queen's are off and now I could
cash in and grab something this pawn is
falling my rook is a little bit out of
place but after this King has to run
elsewhere and I get this pawn could
trade a little bit to block with Bishop
f2 if there's a bishop check just going
to do it anyhow I could fall but I get
this on the bishop no time
and at the end of it the rook has to
block otherwise i get the night King
position okay no time down to the wire
good game Tran Derek let's uh revert
let's go back
all right I upon is saying good game
good game now let's see where we're at
right here this is the first thing that
catches my attention I don't have to
worry as much about my D foursquare if
you play knight c6 and I what did I do
after after Bishop hang on let me let me
make clear my thoughts here let me relay
what I'm really thinking after night d 7
i'm able to play Bishop to d3 i don't
have to worry as much about my d
foursquare however if you play knight c6
and I play Bishop d3 i'm giving black an
opportunity to post a night on the d4
square excuse me in the following way if
after 96 Bishop d3 you have a 5 and if
I'm responding with d5 you could play
night to d4 and there might be some
instances where if white gives up their
light square Bishop and gets a pond I
think there's some pressure that black
could still be placing against white
moving the night opening up the position
black after all is castled so I would
look into knight c6 and this a 5 move
which is still a book line and it's it's
booked for a reason is because it is
coordinating well on the d4 square and
that's something to keep in mind here
another thing is that if you're going to
play knight c6 and not follow up with e
5 that's a problem you really do need to
play knight c6 with this being your
paunch strike you do have to crack at
this structure here in some way and if
it's not going to be your sepan with c5
then it had better be your epon so keep
that in mind so you can look into knight
c6 in the e5 will however you run with
the c5 move this could definitely turn
into
a Sicilian structure where there's the
oxy bind c4e four moves f3 is maybe a
little bit weird in that set up similar
structure this is a dragon set up and I
think this is where black goes a bit of
straight because I plant my knight in
the center with tempo you take my night
away but I don't know there's just an
overwhelming space advantage here and if
the white side is patient keeping black
guessing with d5 capture it's tough to
meet both different structural changes
so those early suggestions I would
really look into maybe the knight c6 and
c5 move but I mean you're not you're not
losing here but it's just I think tough
to come up with a constructive plan
right now it's a little bit awkward
capturing away from the center I wonder
I wonder how things would turn out if
you do it like this it is still a little
bit Airy over here for your Kings side
but I won't be able to make use of d5 so
easily you could say that for sure if
you're taking with your Jeep on you have
your epon around watching over that but
I think as white I'm just needing to
find a good good way to make
improvements this is a not the easiest
thing to be coming up with in a chess
game this these these plans in the
middle game and what what I find about
myself and when I'm in the middle game
what I do a lot is reassess the position
of my pieces because once you're out of
the opening phase you have let's say
your nights on classical squares as
white such as f3 right here let's say
the Knights on f3 and another one's on
c6 eventually you're done with the
opening you've gotten your pieces out
you're at that fully developed stage and
then it's like well what do I do what
plan do I run with or how can I make
improvements to the pieces that are
already out in the opening it said
you really shouldn't move the same piece
more than once in the opening but once
you're past the opening then you're
looking for these repositioning type of
moves and that's what I tend to do a lot
of and this right here is an example of
that I'm identifying this guy as being
the one who needs the most work so
that's why I was running with Bishop c22
a4 where I thought it could be quite
annoying keeping an eye on that eh
square so this this turns out to be
awkward now very difficult having to
work around this guy okay and I should
have done this and move earlier so this
was a slip-up by me as well instead of
the pond push I could go here
immediately and then land a fork on e6
but ok let me close out good game Derek